but didn't you already sign a fight with
Connor saying you guys will fight our
ultimate fighter contract says that yes
nobody's better at the pr game
manipulation of the headlines and Connor
and his team audar just a couple days
ago his manager was talking yeah
Chandler is probably the most likely
opponent but there's still other options
out there it's like no there's not any
other options out there Audi but it's
smart for you to say that it's smart for
you to try to get inside my head that
this fight might not actually happen
little do you know I'm bulletproof and I
can wait this out as long as you want
you want to try to retire me I'll retire
you right back you want to try to wait
me out okay I'm going to wait you out
just as long I will stand irm in this
conviction this fight is happening and
there's only one way to get back to the
UFC and the road goes through Nashville
Tennessee I don't know what the holdup
is Conor